bonjour je suis marc bonjour je suis
leonidas n'appelle ses recettes j'ai su
créer là je suis web on a monté notre
tête on était les premiers sont en
marche un peu plus le projet il est né à
quoi il ya un homme idée c'était de
proposer des produits qualité
l'université paris saclay en
collaboration avec les auteurs des
cassos récemment lancé une websérie
originale à l'humour caustique
bonjour je suis leonidas chez sparta
tête nous développons le matériau de
demain
lepers lepers c'est un éco matériaux but
est de stimuler l'envié d'entreprendre
de façon originale
chaque épisode les différents héros de
films ou de séries deviennent des
entrepreneurs et leur façon de faire est
systématiquement tourné en dérision
notre prototype de masques et 9 5 %
végétal au musée d'art aussi les animaux
avec papy factory j'ai voulu combiner
mes deux passions sur papier de riz
pâtes producteur de la série voulais
montrer que les grands entrepreneurs ont
pas tous réussi du premier coup
la web série rencontre un vif succès sur
les réseaux sociaux avec plus de 40000
like sur facebook et près de quarante
neuf mille abonnés sur youtube mais
s'inscrit notamment dans une action
globale et innovante de l'université
paris saclay concernant
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant nous y
reviendront sûrement plus en détail dans
un prochain numéro
et si le coran tu as organisé une
rencontre alors moi j'ai une boîte de
prod et c'est vrai qu'avant j'avais un
peu de mal à marcher et grâce à start up
heroes et bien j'ai compris une chose
très simple tu voulait délocaliser en
chine donc si tu veux te faire des
couilles en or c'est simple tout à bonn
et puis voilà